okay it's a great time for new rules
everybody noodles
all right the rule if you hire someone
like
ben carson did to sandblast bible quotes
into the walls of your home
make sure they know how to spell
proverbs
lest thou appear an idiot
thanks fellas new rule los angelino's
have to stop freaking out about the navy
shooting off ballistic missiles
it hasn't rained here in four years
anything that falls from our sky and
isn't harrison ford
is a nice change
the woman in this australian wine ad who
sets
who sets the wine glass there and says
taste the bush
has to explain to americans under 50
years old
what's a bush
who wrote the magazine's wine spectator
wine advocate wine enthusiast wine and
spirits the world of fine wine and
decanter
stole merge into one magazine called
drunk snob geographic
now that salsa has surpassed ketchup as
america's favorite condiment
donald trump must build a wall around
aisle seven of safeway
back to mexico chili con queso and
refried beans and you too candle of the
virgin mary
you can come back legally but for now we
need those shelves for mayonnaise and
mountain dew
and finally new rules someone must
remind white americans that even though
other people are winning small victories
and making slight gains
you're not losing you're still way way
ahead
for example before the recession whites
had four times the wealth of blacks and
latinos
but since the recession that's gone up
now they have six times as much
so if anyone should be bitching about
wanting their country back
it ain't you
now i bring this up i bring this up
because last week the national academy
of sciences reported that the death rate
for white americans
45 to 54 and no college degree
had risen markedly in this century a
time when an increase in the mortality
rate for any large group is virtually
unheard of
in an advanced nation or even in this
one but middle-aged american whites
are dropping like flies overweight
overweight depressed poorly dressed
flies
dropping from what drugs alcohol
suicide and possibly trying to fit into
skinny jeans
the suicide rate for whites is now four
times the rate for blacks and in the
last decade
90 of the people who tried heroin for
the first time
were white it's hard out there for a
wimp
and that's why tonight i'd like to
remind white people of something
very important they may have forgotten
you're white
cheer the [ __ ] up
jesus look at history it's always a
great time to be white
think of all the advantages
sorry bro think of all the advantages
you have
cops don't shoot you for having your
hands in your pockets
when people follow you around a store
it's because they want to help you find
something
major party presidential candidates
aren't proposing to deport you
you can walk through an entire wedding
reception without anyone trying to order
a drink from you
and how about this perk if you're white
you're much more likely to be
not in prison black blacks and whites
use
marijuana at virtually the same rate not
counting miley cyrus but
but blacks are charged with possession
almost four times as often
and crack cocaine will send you to jail
for much longer
than powder cocaine the preferred brand
of white people
in fact if the cops see a caucasian man
walking down the street with white
powder under his nose
all they say is man that must have been
a great donut
hell you could be a coke cat in an
aimless drunk until you're 40 and still
wind up president of the united states
which reminds me of another great thing
about being white
you could be a complete [ __ ] up and
people still hire you
studies show white applicants with a
criminal record
are as likely to get hired as black
applicants without one prison time
served by blacks deal breaker prison
time served by whites
interesting water cooler conversation
and whites are still first in line for
legacy admissions to
colleges and businesses and politics
because
the well-connected parents of white
people tend to be white
also you're much more likely to be the
boss fortune 500 ceos are 97
white and 3 oprah
the median net worth of a single white
woman 42
000 of a single black woman five
dollars because she spent it all on a
weave
ensure [ __ ] you you politically correct
[ __ ] one joke one joke about the
blacks thank you
there you go like the old joke yeah
in short when you're white you don't
need to be that good
there was a
there was a popular band in the 70s
called the average white band
they admitted they were average but it
didn't matter because they were white